are you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
it will kill
the sword of perseus
son of zeus the greek demigod perseus is
best known for decapitating the gorgon
medusa with his mighty sword
the legendary weapon is described as
having a short leaf shaped blade that
was perfect for cutting slashing and
thrusting
perseus was given this blade by the
greek goddess athena who wanted medusa
destroyed
later in the myth perseus used the head
of medusa to turn the massive kraken sea
monster to stone saving the princess
andromeda
though the story is fiction you can
watch perseus slay medusa in the film
clash of the titans
or visit renowned artist benvenuto
cellini's bronze depiction in florence
italy i don't want to see one turn into
a rock
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
now in greek mythology perseus uses
sword to decapitate medus and remove her
head from her body to use it as a weapon
to that end i will take your weapon and
help me to deliver some killing slashes
and blows to liberate her head from her
body
robert you're up first you ready for
this yes sir let's do this
going into testing i am concerned about
the weight i'm hoping my blade can do
everything that doug wants it to do but
i'm concerned
[Music]
[Music]
all right robert let's talk about your
sword here i like the design that you
have the damascus
in there
but it's so heavy
it's about five pounds over here but the
thing is it's so forward heavy most of
the weights up here when i'm lifting
this i can feel all the stress right
there this is supposed to be meant to be
a single-handed use weapon
now your edge
is plenty sharp it was easy to thrust
and cut and
it will kill
all right jared your turn you ready sir
yes sir let's do this with the test you
never really know what to expect and
anything can go wrong
[Music]
all right jared
first up
you nailed the balance on this as a
one-handed sword it's about three pounds
lighter than your opponents your edge
is razor sharp
every slash is deep the thrust no issues
at all and most importantly sir
it will kill
all right bladesmith next stop is the
strength desk release the jb
all right bladesmiths we took medusa's
head during the kill test now the
kraken's turned to stone so what i'm
gonna do is take your swords and beat
them mercilessly into these stone kraken
heads
it's gonna be brutal
and rob you're up first how you feeling
a little nervous but i'm ready let's do
it this is the make or break test
[Music]
you okay yep bounced off the glove
didn't cut me
oh what's that
my blade breaks my heart breaks
but i am just so glad that it didn't
hurt jay
oh a little bit of a problem here rob
on the tang you can see a black spot so
it means you had a stress fracture there
with the weight of this sword
hitting those stone cracking skulls it
was enough to allow that stress fracture
to just continue all the way across
so
the good part is that your edge
held up so good job on the damascus
but it's kind of hard to swing a sword
by a handle on it
well robert your blade broke after four
strokes on this crack and head but that
doesn't mean that you're out of the
competition jared your blade still has
to survive four strikes jay let's get
crack of lagging
this is it right here
let's see what it did to rob's blade
my sword's got to hold up four swings
and i know jay you know he's going to
try to do some damage
[Music]
[Music]
jared your blade survived
robert unfortunately your blade cannot
continue to be tested in this
competition and for that reason i have
to ask you to please leave the forge
come on forward my friend you killed the
medusa though
it's a heartbreaker but i'm really proud
of what i did
jared
congratulations the strength of your
weapon has ensured that you are the
forced and fire champion leaving this
forge with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother awesome thank
you
thank you
how you feeling right now good how about
a smile or something yeah
[Laughter]
all right come on over and shake our
hands brother good job man yeah
i am the new fortune fire champion
something i never thought i'd say
i can't wait to get home give my
daughters the news and uh
take the 10 grand take my family on a
vacation somewhere
the hattori hanzo a thousand layer
katana
[Music]
whoa
born in 16th century japan hattori hanzo
also known as devil hanzo was perhaps
the most legendary samurai to ever live
almost 400 years later in the 2003
tarantino cult classic kill bill hattori
hanzo was reimagined as the modern day
bladesmith who creates a katana so fine
it would cut god
in reality the katana is the majestic
symbol of the ancient warrior samurai
featuring a simple but elegant
single-edged blade designed for precise
cuts and lightning fast thrusts
the dazzling damascus layering produces
not only a beautiful piece of steel but
an incredibly sharp and deadly cutting
edge
bladesmiths a hanzo's katana's first
duty is to kill to find out what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do i will
take your katana and deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy
all right mike can you up first are you
ready yes sir let's do this
two
[Music]
yes
mike your edge is razor sharp
but more importantly there's bone on
your edge
but your edge did not roll did not chip
and your blade stayed true
overall sir
your blade
will kill
thank you
justin you ready yes sir let's do this
hmm
ah
right tristan
the balance of your blade is very good
it's light it's fast it's easily
maneuverable
but
when steel meets the skull there were
some problems
your blade took a serious bend
also
on the edge right here you took some
chipping but overall
looking at the dummy
i think your weapon will definitely kill
thank you
gentlemen
the second duty of a hanzo katana is
that it is to be sharp
it is said that the hanzo katana is as
sharp as a thousand razor blades
now a sharp blade should cut cleanly
through tatami mats a dull blade will
crush
bend or get hung up
a dull blade
is not a hanzo katana
mike you're up first you ready for this
yes i'm ready
your blade sir is sharp it cut cleanly
to the thickness of our tatami mats but
on the back end slice it did not cut
completely though overall sir
your sword will cut
thank you
tristan your turn you ready ready as
i'll ever be sir
[Music]
sorry
well tristan
your edge is sharp
you can cut through the tummy mats
my concern is the strength of your blade
it picked up another bend
now you have two bends on your blade
especially right here close to the guard
tristan this hollywood competition has
been exciting and dramatic you've been
at the epicenter
of all of that drama
nobody is questioning the strength of
your character however
the strength of your blade is such that
we can no longer continue to test it
for that reason i have to ask you to
please leave a forge
mike you were an unstoppable force in
this competition and your atari hanzo
thousand-layer katana is absolutely
deadly earning you the title of forged
and fire champion and a check for 10
grand good job brother i am forged in
fire champion
and it feels awesome
the sick a sword
the sikka is a short but dangerous sword
widely used by gladiators in ancient
rome since it was customary to fight
with armor the blade featured a sharp
curve specifically designed to get
around an opponent's shield a gruesome
killer warriors would use its lethal
inner edge to sever limbs or the blade's
deadly point to hook into the jaw and
pierce through the head today the sick
is often depicted in popular culture
during graphic gladiator battles most
notably in the television series
spartacus blood and sand
blade smiths this is the kill test i'll
take your seeker sword and deliver
killing blows on this ballistics dummy
frank you're up first you ready hell
yeah let's do this
nice
well frank your blade is sharp
in combat the sitka is sometimes used in
this curve to pull away the sword and
come in in this case he pulled away the
head
overall your weapon
will kill thank you
tony you ready
let's have some fun
all right tony this is a scary sick a
sword on the initial hack into the chest
cavity it penetrated so deep it totally
demolished this ballistics dummy overall
sir your weapon
will kill
tony's blade just performs great on this
thing i mean even though they both will
kill his just looked a little bit more
violent so it has me a little a little
nervous
gentlemen this is the strength test in
order to test the strength and
durability of your blades i'm going to
attack these shields
remember this test is all about what the
shields do to your weapons and not what
your weapons do to the shields frank
you're up first are you ready yep let's
do this
[Music]
well frank
your edge held up perfectly all right
it's still straight it's still sharp
everything is still tight and solid
well done thank you
tony you're up next are you ready yes
well tony
your edge held up perfectly as well
razor sharp i see
no problem with the edge from the shield
you know
a nice solid blade well done thank you
good job
all right gentlemen
now it's the sharpness test i'll be
cutting through this sugar cane one cut
with the front edge of your blade one
cut with the back edge all right frank
you're up first you ready oh yes
[Music]
all right frank right off your blade's
got a really nice balance to it
you can see on that first cut it kind of
pulled in my hand but it's still a good
feel on the back cut blew right through
any gladiator using this be quick be
deadly well done thank you all right
tony you're up you ready for this yep
so tony
is it sharp yes it's very sharp and it
cut very nicely
still right still tight
hold on thanks
blade smiths over the course of three
rounds both of you has displayed
excellent bladesmithing talents however
in this arena of competition there can
only be one champion
tony
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion
frank unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut please surrender your blade
i'm fine with this result they both
killed but
he's uh really killed
tony's already invited me to come up
there and forage he's going to show me
some stuff
i'll know tony probably the rest of my
life
tony congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job how do you feel right now
i feel pretty good all right well tony
please present your weapon to the judges
just
okay i'm still here it's not a dream
i won it's awesome
how do you put it in words
game of saw on the concord
then zombie nulu
nombe nulu was a ceremonial sword made
by the nambe tribe of the democratic
republic of the congo featuring an
ornate wooden hilt and an embellished
scythe-shaped blade this intimidating
weapon was reputedly used around the
late 19th century for the sacrificial
beheading of tribal slaves
the razor sharp outer edge of the hook
was said to separate the victim's head
from his neck in one swift fatal strike
following the abolition of human
sacrifice the nulu transitioned from
executioner's weapon to an insignia
prestige carried at ceremonial dances
bladesmiths this is the kill test the
number noodle wasn't just a weapon used
by tribal chiefs to show status it was
also known as the beheading sword of the
congo
so to see what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
nambidullo and i'll deliver lethal
slashes on this ballistics dummy
and oh i'm gonna try to take its head
off
they're gonna actually cut the head off
of this dummy
who does that
oh my god
that was badass
all right paul let's talk about your
number nulu it feels good in the hand
it's got a razor's edge here that upon
its initial delivery into the gut that
dug in deep all the way into the bowel
now for its intended purpose of going up
to decapitate the head
well come on it's got no head it's dead
your weapon
will kill thank you all right stephen
it's your turn you ready yes sir i'm
gonna
head on over and grab your sword
i'm a nervous dude and i really hope
that my blade hangs with his
[Music]
all right steven
your blade is sharp it lacerated all the
way into the bowels
you can see that cuts through the jaw
and all the way through the head
the wood that you have here is smooth
but it's the indexing that you have for
that the way you have it flattened out
and avoid that feels good in the hand
yes sir
and it will kill thanks
gentlemen this is the sharpness test to
test the sharpness of your blades i'll
be cutting into our cane man here
paul you ready yes
this is what i love to see come back in
the third round this feels like a weapon
it cuts like a weapon it went right
through that cane you nailed it thank
you all right stephen you ready for this
yes sir
your weapon same weapon
different feel it's a different weight
it's a different balance but the cuts
you can see it just passed right through
there wasn't any resistance on that cane
nicely done it feels good to have made
something that's effective
gentlemen to test the strength and
durability of your blades i'm going to
chop into these clay pots this is not
about what your blades do to the pots
but what these pots can do to your
blades
paul you're up first
i'm hitting something as hard as a clay
pot i don't have any idea what it's
going to do to my edge
the balance is really nice on this it's
heavy where it needs to be heavy when
you're swinging it you know where it's
going all right there's a slight roll on
the edge of your blade right here that i
can get a fingernail on that
everything down at the handle and the
guard are still tight yeah other than
that one roll seems to have held up well
all right stephen you're ready for this
yes sir okay
nice and straight i don't really see
anything out of alignment your blades a
little bit heavier
than paul's but it's got a good feel
it's got a good balance the wood you've
got in the handle and the extension this
handle has put the balance in a really
nice place oh
yeah i can't feel any deformation on the
edge
well done thank you
paul stephen the judge's deliberation is
complete and they've made their final
decision the forged and fire champion is
stephen congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion
paul unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut paul you both made
beautiful weapons and they both
performed beautifully too so then we had
to look at the finest of details
and that rolled edge in the strength
test
well that was his tithing factor so
that's why we have to send you home
i understand paul thank you very much
for turning in such a beautiful weapon
but now i have to ask you to surrender
it and please leave the forge
i certainly accept the judge's decision
my edge rolled in stevenson first thing
i'm going to do when i get home is clean
my shop and get on with what i usually
make
steven congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion and will be
receiving a check for 10 grand how do
you feel i feel great
it's a little surreal i damn well proved
what i came here to prove i am creative
and that i can make a functional weapon
and that you want to be the most
experienced if you put your heart into
stuff things you know can turn out well
it was fun as hell and i'm glad that i
came out on top
the waldo
the waldow is a pole arm weapon that has
been wielded by korean warriors since
the 6th century the large crescent blade
provided the user with incredible force
that delivered lethal blows and deep
cuts with one swing into an opponent
historically this heavy weapon required
special skills and was only wielded in
battle by elite korean warriors today
korean martial artists who specialize in
the waldo perform intricate maneuvers
with this intimidating weapon at
festivals and cultural events
baitsmiths annyeonghaseyo and welcome to
the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i will take your
weapons and deliver lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy
eric you up first you ready for this yes
sir
all right eric let's talk about your
waldo here it is forward heavy there's a
lot of metal in here but it is wieldable
now your edge is sharp it penetrates
deeply into this bilix's tummy cutting
the gel torso and into the bones overall
sir you're a waldo
it will kill
thank you
all right dave your turn sir are you
ready yes sir let's do this
all right dave talk about your waldo
here it is a little bit heavier than the
other weapon heavier weapons require a
lot of adjustments but your edge here is
sharp with this forward weight that cuts
deep into this ballistics dummy and cuts
the bones inside but in doing so sir
your edge over here did take a little
bit of rolling
but the other parts
are fine
and overall sir your waldo
you will keel
thank you
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
we're calling this one the bamboo man
attack
to test the overall construction of your
blade i'm going to take them and gently
tap them against our bamboo man over
here
now remember this is not about what your
weapons do to these targets it's about
what these targets do your weapons eric
you're up first you ready yes sir all
right
[Music]
so eric right off this is a heavy beast
your balance point's not bad i kind of
like that right there
where you can manipulate the weapon
as far as the weapon performance goes
you maintain an edge all the way along
it's still sharp nicely done thank you
all right dave you're up ready yes sir
uh
[Music]
all right dave
your weapon
is really really heavy so
you can make a devastating cut
but recovery is is really slow
as far as the blade
the blade itself is is dented
sideways here
and up above here
but
still solid so you survived quite nicely
well done dave thank you
bladesmiths this is the sharpness test
the sugar cane slice
to find out how sharp your weapons are
i'm gonna attempt to cut through all
these sugar canes
unlike the strength test this is all
about what your weapons do and how well
they cut the sugar canes
eric are you ready to do this yes sir
[Music]
all right eric let's talk about your
edge here
your edge
it's sharp it cut through all the sugar
canes and overall sir your weapon you'll
cut
thank you
dave it's your turn sir you ready for
this yes sir
damn
all right dave let's talk about your
weapon here
it's still sharp
and it cuts cleanly all the way through
but the weight of your blade as i'm
cutting dragged downward and i ran out
of sugar cane but overall sir your
weapon you will cut thank you
well gentlemen you both performed
extremely well in our korean theme
challenge both your waldos did great
during our tests
but this is a competition and there has
to be a winner the judges have made the
decision
and today's fortune fire champion is
eric congratulations
now dave you fought hard but
unfortunately you're not today's winner
your time in this competition has ended
and for that reason i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor
good job man
well eric you know what that means you
are the newest fortune fire champion
you're gonna be walking out of here with
a check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
i feel awesome coming out here winning
the competition having my skills
validated this is a crowding achievement
of mine well done thank you
if somebody wants me to make a waldo
it's going to cost him 10 grand
you